[Music]
I'm Alexander Spencer I'm the creative
director and co-founder of realization
and I think that realization is a
culmination of everything that book
telling myself had worked on for the
past ten years so at the time that we
started it I had just finished living in
New York for four years and she had a
clothing label that she wanted to you
know step away from in something new and
we had this discussion about how
basically we didn't feel that there was
an e-commerce or a retailer that
reflected the times you know III by self
never really lived in one place and
Moore had shared so before of creating
collections and having seasonal
collections
you know trying to sell something six
months out was not really working
anymore I think you know a lot of what
we do is so replicated everywhere if you
walk down the road whether it's a high
street rat or someone you know really
famous or whatever it is they think that
authenticity is the brand this is what
sets us apart
I'm not wholly trained in any of the
things I'm
at all I never wanted these Photoshop
the right way and everyone how to take
note of the right way just to get it out
my way of learning was always by doing
it myself as opposed to somebody telling
me how to do it just having these huge
people huge amazing companies that you
love so much saying yeah I mean take
what's your version of it I think
anytime you get asked the question and
if any level of user you feel that's the
most excited
[Music]